but one of the first times I smoked like
a high-grade joint was with Mike really
after the show and I was completely out
of my mind I was completely out of my
mind afterwards and I had to go host a
charity event
[Laughter]
[Music]
hey everybody welcome to another episode
of hot box and I'm Evan Britton and I'm
Mike Tyson Mike today we've got a legend
in here man a national treasure if I
might say so I would love to meet him
where is he we got the one and only
Jimmy Kimmel the one and only being yeah
thank you I'm happy to be here wow this
is some operation you guys that's pretty
I mean do a podcast it's like the corner
of somebody's office you've got a whole
party going on you have the whole
building here got plans it's humble
really it's not very stoner like to have
this much going on anybody you have I'm
stoner tendencies yeah yeah this
happened you're really smashing
stereotypes absolutely really happy to
see we all love you see you know with
the ears and stuff they seen when we
host the show together oh yeah
I love having me on you know you were on
what like the first month we were on it
yes yeah a great time yeah yeah really
yeah I was telling my brother-in-law the
other law Eirik closer man if you want
he said don't be afraid don't be afraid
brother dude I was telling him last
night that we Mike and I shot a
Christmas we did a Christmas song
together he did yes we did
it was winter wonderland a great sweater
and and it this almost never happens but
in the middle of the shoot it was like a
three-hour shoot I got a call from my
son's school my son's now 25 years old
and so he was up to something I don't
know he got he was in trouble and I said
I'm sorry I have to leave for about an
hour
and Mike's like it's okay don't worry
about I understand so I went got my son
and Mike waited for an hour which I was
very grateful for and we get back and
Mike said I'm gonna talk to your son and
Mike's at my son down and had this the
greatest conversation with him I kind of
went off to the side because I wanted
them to be alone together but Mike
you're telling them like you know I had
trouble in school and but you have to
you know really encouraging him and
telling him sharing your story of of
being a kid and having problems and I
really was just like wow this Lily
didn't stuff yeah and it was it was
really it was fantastic and then I told
him that if he screwed up again you
would beat the [ __ ] out of him he didn't
know though I yeah
but it was very sweet actually that is
but that's Mike that is Mike and L don't
know that yeah most people don't know
that sighs what is it Mike from Brooklyn
to what you ant now yeah I moved when I
was nine years old to Las Vegas from
Brooklyn my parents Vegas Oakland um
it's a weird story and I actually just
learned some detail so my family not my
parents but my aunt and uncle my uncle
Frank who you remember he visited you in
Brooklyn my Uncle Frank retired he was a
New York police officer 20 years he
retired and he wanted to move to Florida
so they went to Florida and they put a
down payment on a house in Florida and
they're staying with some friends nearby
and out in the backyard in the pool was
an alligator and they were like there's
no [ __ ] way we live in this place
with alligators and they lost the
deposit on their house and they decided
to move to Vegas instead they moved to
Vegas and about a year later they took
my grandparents with them and we were
like you know what we need to go be with
the family so we just followed the
family out there had almost nothing to
do with Vegas itself amazing so awesome
and you got involved with entertainment
in Vegas kind of not really I was you
know I worked at a clothing store I
delivered pizzas but there was a guy at
the store I work I worked at a store
called Miller's outpost it was like
Levi's and stuff yeah
and this guy worked at the college radio
station I was in high school and he said
you know you're funny you'd be good on
the radio and I thought well I'd love to
be on the radio and he made a call and
he got me in a meeting with the program
director and then they they didn't hire
me but you know they let me do a
half-hour interview show on Sunday
nights and I would do the show and go
home and my parents had listened and
they were very excited and I just really
got turned on by you know the idea that
people were listening to a show that I
was hosting and that's when I decided I
wanted to be in radio which is where I
started was that before or after ASU
that was before I was in high school oh
really then I went to UNLV for a year
and then I went to Arizona State which
has a great broadcasting program correct
it does I wasn't really a part of that
and it didn't really have anything to do
with but yeah they do have a solid
broadcasting program yeah you have had
to drive this is what I want to do I
just got excited but I just loved it I
didn't even think of it as like what am
I going to do for a living I just wanted
to be on the radio and I started
listening to Howard Stern and my uncle
would send me tapes from New York and I
loved Howard Stern and I loved David
Letterman and so I just started doing it
and I lived in I got fired from my
college radio job I got a job in Phoenix
I got fired from that job I got a job in
Seattle I got fired from that job I
moved to tan I didn't move back in with
my parents and Phoenix moved to Tampa
Florida got fired from that job moved to
Palm Springs I did not get fired from
that job I then got another job in
Tucson got fired from that job well you
hey what were you doing at you getting
yeah yeah I was doing basically the same
stuff that I do now but it wasn't
appreciated like I didn't have any
respect for like my bosses and I didn't
understand that you had to be diplomatic
and I would make fun of them I would
tape meetings in which they'd yell at us
and then play them back on the air the
next morning sometimes I call their
wives or girlfriends at home
to get information about them then share
on the air I do crazy things and then I
couldn't understand why I would I'd been
fired but I always thought the boss
understood that he was there to be
mocked and that was you know what people
wanted to hear you driving to work you
want to hear some guy [ __ ] with his
boss you know it's fun but they never
liked it at all
so I got fired and then I got a job at K
Rock here in LA and I worked there for
five years and that's when living in LA
being on the radio I would get phone
calls from television producers saying
hey you know why don't you come in and
audition for this or whatever and it
never really occurred to me that I might
be on television but I just did it
because I wanted to make extra money and
so I went and audition for a couple of
things and I wound up on a game show
called with money which was on Comedy
Central and from there we pitched them
the man show and I did football picks on
Fox and then I wound up getting the show
my block really Jimmy did Know Who Lived
are your brothers dying dying well
that's right you guys were neighbors
right that's what a neighborhood
seriously did you ever stop by her
hangout pass each other's honesty going
to the store all the time yeah hello yes
yeah Ben's Ben's good Jimmy do you feel
like if you had been diplomatic
throughout your radio career you'd be
where you are now
no I think what would have happened
weirdly is I would have kept those jobs
and probably still been in Tampa or
something yeah you know yeah and so it
worked out it would definitely wasn't my
plan it wasn't any stroke of genius it
just so happened to be and the truth is
when I got the job in LA I could have
you know I could have been anywhere you
just happen to be in LA if I was in
another big market like Chicago or
something you know maybe that nobody
know TV producers are listening to the
show and I never get that phone call so
absolutely a lot of luck was involved
tell people I said Nam sometimes that
I'm not steering the ships my steering
this ship for me because yeah no way
accomplish the things that I'm not smart
enough it's it's you know luck is a huge
part of it and anyone who tells you
differently is full of themselves you
just have to be ready when the luck
strikes do you were lucky you are
that's right and and the most more you
make up the opportunities for sure like
with you boxing like there's no luck
involved right I mean it's no the harder
you work the luckier you become yeah the
only luck you'd might have is that you
get judges who judge the fight properly
you know I don't know sometimes you
fight and are getting injured sometimes
your I don't know did it happen in
football sometimes you're fighting in a
fight you hit anything I didn't hit that
guy that hard and the guys out cold yeah
I've had proposed to no no way that
guy's faking him and in that heart yeah
that's definitely not happened to me in
my profession I've never something you
say the joke and the whole people your
Diner that jokes not that [ __ ] funny
oh all the time yeah every night now the
serious I'm not I'm being serious there
are nights where I go out and I feel
like I have great jokes and they don't
get a good response and there are nights
I go out I have jokes that are not so
great that do get a good response what
the [ __ ] is wrong with these people and
it's it's interesting there's just uh
you just you just have to understand
this the same way in sports but how did
that punk that punch and I'm not wait I
put you know
then he assumed he had it by the punch
yeah oh no [ __ ] way that's cuz you
hit him perfectly we just went through
it sometime it's almost like the vine is
why I didn't even though the punch with
no accuracy it just blew me it's gonna
happen how did that happen hmm
yeah you know who was that you were
fighting where he said you hit him and
you were like [ __ ] I just killed that
guy yeah that was that yeah you feel
like you missed him I did I missed the
punch that was just how cold say he take
pleasure watching the those moments from
your fights where you knock a guy out
cold not anymore not anymore
really yeah because I once hit a home
run in a celebrity softball game really
and it was on ESPN and I hit it over the
fence I've probably watched it a
thousand times
I can't stop watching it
I get so much pleasure I watch it all
you know there was a year or maybe two
years on my show where anytime I went to
a clip for any guest I would
accidentally go to that clip I would
rather watch us on film for mourlot
really don't watch that like I gotta
tell you something I'm gonna make it
come back into the NFL I know I know
it's crazy I don't know I don't know if
I'm in NFL football shape foot you know
everything we talked about man it's just
like you know living your truth in the
will of the universe and I just feel
like I'm being pulled back in the
football man I don't think we can do
this podcasting mic mic you're wearing
the rake on wireless earphones they're
so stylish and discreet I didn't even
notice them it is great khans it's more
I don't even know that any that but I
hear them really well aren't they half
the price of premium earbuds yeah go to
buy rake on Comm slash Tyson to get 15%
off rake on wireless earbuds if you've
been eyeing a pair now is the time to
get an amazing deal go to buy rake on
Comm forward slash Tyson for 15% of them
when was the first time you guys met
tell me about that Jimmy no waste didn't
- remember the first time we actually
met I mean I was involved when I was on
the radio and a couple of press
conferences where I was amongst a sea of
people but that so we didn't really meet
them but the first time we met I think
was I think it was at the show I think
it was yeah I think that was the first
time that we really met well year was
that thousand three two thousand three
yeah Wow early 2003 for sure yeah but
I've been following you in fact Iram
I was in rehab doing the show though oh
really I was on I was a sports guy at
k-rock as I mentioned and we were off
the van der Holyfield fight yeah that
was a Saturday night and we were off the
next we were off the next week the show
was dark and we cherished our vacations
we only got to vacation weeks a year but
I was so charged up after watching that
fight that I called the radio station I
said I know nobody else is there but I'm
coming in and I guess I had to be on the
air to talk about that fine what
happened and I did a whole thing I used
to do an imitation of you and I do you
know I just I thought he was I thought
he was you 12 with funny gotta take a
little nibble out of Athiya of the year
Oh something like that and things in my
life you know you like those moments
that you feel like you know like I
remember when Elvis died and I remember
in a you remember these big moments
that's one of them to me that when that
happened in that fight and what is most
remarkable to me is not because I could
see maybe in the heat of the bout it the
first time he nipped them on but it's to
me really is that it happened and I saw
a van der about six months ago and he's
got a real good sense of humor about the
whole thing I've seen in fact as soon as
I saw him I go hold on let me check it I
looked at it at both of his ears and he
just started laughing you know people do
that to him all the time they want to
look at his ears yeah I bet
well it was in the heat of the battle
man you know I know I know I can't
answer that but but I loved it well you
get pretty you get into some pretty
heated debates and arguments especially
with the but there's no providing
there's never yeah there's never any
physicality at night physical violence
you know yes that's just abideth is not
to bite the actor's encounter actually
but it's the feeling of the bite you
still have the same feeling even if it's
just
she no [ __ ] scar or something
somebody insulted you or something right
yeah yeah I for me I enjoy fighting in
that way I like it you know I like those
roast type situations where you kind of
going back and forth I feel like if you
were to spend time with my family you
would understand why because there's a
lot of just kind of making fun of each
other that goes on there's a lot of
insults thrown around and so it feels
very natural to me it feels familial
yeah well you know you're talking about
your path your non diplomatic approach
yes yeah but you were really just being
yourself and not and again not by any
kind of not no master plan right no
smarts involved I specifically remember
I was hosting a game show and it was
like in an office you know we were
practicing or we're just rehearsing and
I saw this other guy there were two game
shows going at the same time and there
was this guy and he was really good he
was very smooth and he looked good and I
was wearing like my father-in-law's
sport jacket you know it's too big on me
I look stupid and he was really good and
I just thought oh I can't do I can I'll
never be as good as he is at this and
I'd better just just go up there as
myself and not even try to be a host and
that has not being able to do that was a
great gift for me because if I was able
to do that maybe I would have become one
of those guys who winds up hosting the
Miss America pageant every year right
yeah exactly I mean that's why your show
is so awesome for so long well a lot of
it's luck but you know a lot of it's
just pushing a rock up the hill yeah
that's most of it it's just grind and
work hard every night you're on every
night you just have that fear of bombing
fear of failing is the greatest thing
for motivating me anyway we get what
people say Fayette think about what
you're gonna say and think about
yourself
bahama right there when you throw
something out there that you think is
really funny and nobody laughs I'll feel
you train as hard as you training for
the day right right and foot the foot
the foot the fight of your life me you
didn't win
how can I lose I did everything wrong
yeah yeah everybody goes through that at
some point I think so or maybe not I
don't know maybe maybe not maybe people
don't most people probably don't pick
one thing and work that hard at it you
know because obviously it's very
specific what you do and what I do but
you know paying jobs same things that
our hands the pain of failing yeah
fighting pain you don't get hit a punch
but and I get beat up every round and
knocked up the same pain yeah the
cleaner and what you believe you were
the best in but most people are able to
hide that most people's failures aren't
on pay-per-view
so yeah for most people they don't
really a world is in your head yeah
pay-per-view is in your head when you
feeling and showing you think only
10,000 people that's your world
yeah that's your paid the view the same
punishment nothing like the same equal
yeah maybe so I don't know I always look
at those big moments and I go I cannot
screw this up I have to do everything I
possibly can to make sure that I'm
prepared and I'm gonna be funny like
hosting the Oscars or something like
that it's like that's I guess my version
of like a fight you know
subconsciously that's a lot of help from
God to the you know things we do a lot
of that you know yes we're not even
thinking about it we do that right yeah
and from from anyone from God from my
writers from the audience that's the big
thing you can't control it's like you
just you know you can be ready you just
don't know how it's gonna be received
you have no idea I don't know when I did
my show and I guess and I got this
received well I thought wow you're that
funny is that good I understand people
yeah and yeah you don't it's funny
because to the audience they're like oh
this is great Mike Tyson's telling
stories about his life but to you it's
like all right as anyone could be
interested in the story about my life
and pans go under the new show now yeah
there's no more yeah think that and that
insecurity of course is always there I
think in the vast majority of people
like we do our show in Brooklyn every
October you know we'll travel in New
York and the first time we went I was
really worried because we had a big
venue is like 5,000 seats or something
and I was like how are we gonna be able
to like it's okay
you know are people gonna care to come
there are all these other talk shows in
New York you know there's a million
things to do it's not like they're there
it's it's New York it's the biggest city
it's the most exciting city in the world
is anybody gonna come to this and then
that first night there were thousands of
people in line to come to the show and I
was just like I was more than anything I
was relieved I was like thank God
because I could just imagine being in a
half-empty room and being like nobody
likes me
yeah [ __ ] yeah it's but it never goes
away I mean that time we've been doing
the show for 13 years or something you
know it still is the kind of thing that
I think about what do you think you
think do you think it's the how
empowered steering your ship well no I
actually I am a religious person and I
do you know I I do believe in a higher
power and I believe that whatever
religion we decide to affiliate
ourselves with that ultimately the most
important thing is being kind to other
people and I think that's you know
that's that's number one and number one
through ten I think in any religion so I
I do feel like that and I do pray and I
do that kind of stuff I wouldn't say
that I don't go to church every week and
there was a time in my life that I did
do that
but I do think that that there's that if
you behave if you are a good person that
your life will be better so what do you
think about when you no longer exist
what do you think about that
you know I've been thinking about it a
lot lately and I think I very much want
to believe that there's a heaven and
afterlife and and I hope that I will be
judged well but why do you feel you're
gonna be judged for something well I
grew up Catholic and there's that jut
you know there's that's the whole thing
you know you're gonna be judged when you
enter those pearly gates and if you were
good you're gonna go to heaven and if
you're a bad you're goin to hell that's
like that's what I grew up believing and
being told and it you know it's an
appealing thought because it you do want
there to be some reward for not being
totally self-centered and and greedy and
and all of those things so but I don't
know that just because we want something
to be true that it is but I did figure
this out and I think this is a to me
this was a revelation and I'm not sure
I'll be able to express it properly but
like for instance I have a lot of stuff
like I have a lot of mementos that I've
saved over the years you know pictures
and this and that and whatever and I'm
always like well what am I gonna do with
this stuff I don't want to lose it I
have to store it but it can't be in the
middle you know what what do I do with
this stuff and then I think about when I
die
whatever happens whether there's an
afterlife or there's none or whatever it
doesn't matter
like if I were to die today and you know
a lot of people would say he never got
the chance to just kind of retire and go
fishing like he wanted to he never got a
chance to do that to them that will be
an issue to me it won't because the
lights will be out and so I've learned
to not really worry about it because
whatever happens that moment you die
it's not your problem anymore hmm I
don't know if that makes any sense
it makes I'm not even high and I was
high but when the lights are out you
know whatever is on the other side or
isn't it makes no difference you're not
here anymore
and here's another thing do you believe
in ghosts do I believe in
I could yeah I could believe I probably
feel the same way I don't I wouldn't say
with a hundred percent certainty I
definitely never go like a traditional
spirit that lives in the house you know
sure I survive on that if there was such
a thing as ghosts
wouldn't hospitals be just full of them
like wouldn't every hospital have a
million ghosts in it I think some are
maybe so those are not the ones I want
to spend on i.t but well there's so much
there's a lot of stories about nurses
and doctors talking about the spirits
they see during yeah during their
hospital hours like seeing somebody walk
through a hall and then you know losing
sight of that person and then going to
check on a certain room and that person
being deceased so having seen that
spirit come in well you know whatever it
was I would love to see something like
that
I really would I could I believe we
should we reach our Heights potential
only no longer exist I said we have to
be tight of here talking about ourselves
in my head we have to be thinking about
ourselves all of that don't you get
tired then you want to kill ever to [ __ ]
up interesting I'm not sure I have that
same thought but that is interesting you
have that you get tired of thinking
about yourself yeah well that's all
there is probably good by the way it's
probably good quality because people who
think about nothing but themselves
generally aren't great people
now listen but we think about yourself
you see all your flaws what is my
purpose begin here but you should see
all your flaws so that you can be aware
of them and improve I think the worst
people don't see any of their flaws yeah
no yeah that's a quality we were talking
about it yesterday Mike you know I think
that's a very important quality for a
human being to
be aware of your thoughts and your why
did I get gave yer my thought come from
where's my throat to think that I need
to be taught taught about it think those
to be seen I thought I'm a specialist of
where did that thought come from yeah I
come from nothing my parents come from
why would I even think that something
and then the brain is it's we we don't
know anything about our brains really
like even just dreaming is such a
strange thing and it it's so random and
it just seems like maybe our brain is
trying to prepare us for other
situations while we're sleeping and it
could go from like you can have you can
be dreaming about like you you see
somebody on television and then you're
having sex with that person and then one
second later your grandparents are
sitting on the couch watching it grandma
what are you doing here and then you
start crying because you miss your
grandmother this is like what the [ __ ]
is going on in there yeah I mean well
that's a really interesting thing dreams
- waking reality and how do we even know
the difference between the two I mean we
go to sleep at night and when you wake
up the next day I don't know how do you
know you're actually awake how do you
know where how you know this really how
do you know this is real and then
another thing is I was listening to ever
listen to Alan Watts know what this is
amazing Alan Watts is incredible so he
was talking about how the only reason we
can differentiate between memories and
the present moment is there's a
different synapse that happens in our
brains but otherwise it's really
difficult or difficult but the lines get
very blurred between our memories of our
life and what's happening in the present
moment
you know because many memories that we
have can be as clear as the day that
we're in in the present moment were in
and what he says about that is that
leads you into
this understanding of time as being
nonlinear you know and everything is
really happening at once it's just the
way our brain structures time and
consciousness that we experience it in
this linear fashion I hope people are
stoned when they're listening to this
because I think they're really we'll be
able to get into it if they are yeah
it's the perspective can you reach a
certain age do something like you say
this a you start to really question your
mortality yeah yeah you think about it
but I'm I'm trying not to worry about it
what I don't like is not being able to
read a menu in a restaurant those are
the times where my age will bother me
when I can't like see whose your
eyesight yeah yeah and that's that's
some serious that's serious like oh I'm
like a I'm like a I'm nothing more than
a baseball glove that you know you buy
it and you're nine years old and it's
shiny and new and then you break it in
and it gets to a point where it's kind
of perfect and then it starts getting
hard and and the laces start breaking
and you want to restring it but it's
never quite the same and then you throw
it in the garbage you know and that's us
we're just like a piece of leather yeah
maybe not in many ways this this meat
vehicle that we're inhabited for a
moment it is it's like a there's an
expiration date
absolutely have you ever thought about
what compels you to do the work that you
do what is it that in your spirit that
you're just able to project your truth
at all times whatever that might be
I just I don't I don't really know the
answer and it's a very good question I
don't know what compels me I think
probably it's a it's a lot of things I
think like for I mean there was a point
in my life where I had no money at all
and that's what compelled I was like oh
I have to work on this I have to get
this going I have to try to put this
pitch together just to be able to
support my family really what did that
money me
you feel like that make you feel like a
man that that that's what you need to be
a man and the family rule the family
yeah for sure it definitely I think it's
something that is expected of you and
you're a boy and then you become a man
and I got married very young I married I
was 20 years old and I was suddenly in a
situation where I'd never made really
more than like you know $75 a day you
know and I had to and my ex-wife worked
also but then we had kids not long
afterwards and I embarked on this career
that got me you know I got fired a lot
of times and like it sounds funny and it
sounds fun when I list all the places I
worked and got fired but it wasn't funny
or run at that time because I'd actually
have to pack the house and move to
another city with the whole family yeah
with the winds is you it wasn't just me
yeah
and that's hard to explain to your wife
sometimes and it's hard to explain to
your parents sometimes and sometimes
people start going like so what's you
know like what's the plan B you know
like that's what I would be like there
is no plan B right only a plan a there
are no other letters in the plan and I
always just thought like that and I
don't know why but I think part of it is
you just enjoy the attention you get
from being funny in class and that was
something I always loved you know
screwing around with my friends being
funny and you like that that feeling and
then when somebody actually pays you to
do that it's a very powerful combination
and you want that attention and you want
that that feedback that you get and all
of those things I found to be very
rewarding and I you know I think you
know that's ultimately if I had to boil
it down to anything I love making I love
the feeling of making people laugh yeah
and then that just kind of all these
other things came from that I think that
tying that to something you said about
your own spirituality of being
and one through ten I think making
people laugh and spreading joy is
definitely a form of kindness and you
can do it on a massive scale man you
know well that's what's great you know
it's it really makes you feel like like
oh I'm I must be real I must be funny I
know this makes me sound like an [ __ ]
but I once watch it's all good brother I
walked into my house and you know I have
a nice house and I looked around and I
was well I must be very funny this house
for it yeah yeah it's weird you live in
LA I do yeah so what do you think about
the booming cannabis industry it's you
know I remember going to Amsterdam and
being so excited that it was just there
for purchase and it is I think it's
still exciting you know and maybe that
will wear off and like in like 15 years
people will be like yeah of course you
can just go and buy whatever you want
but every once in a while I'll go into
one of these shops and I just can't
believe it it's like I look at this you
know we had to do to get this stuff you
had to know a guy who knew a guy and I
had to get it for it took so [ __ ]
long dude exchange
yeah and and I don't know that I'll ever
get over that and now I have plant in my
back yard and I'll I grow it and I love
that too you know so the idea that you
can just grow it and roll your arm it's
like you know it's pretty great really
yeah and I feel the same way about
vegetables by the way but even more so
about being able to just grow in so I go
there comes out of the ground and yeah
of course I'm a vegetables Nightingale
well I could I grow tomatoes some
Nightingale that
the poisonous nightshade vegetables
right yeah yeah what like eggplant is
supposed to be no good for you
shaky-shaky
yeah I figure anything that comes out of
the grounds got to be okay I mean for
the most part yeah better than the meat
that we eating huh yeah yeah definitely
better than that yeah but not that I've
stopped but the processes are just
[ __ ] up of industrial meat yes before
they give it to us guys yeah yeah I have
mixed feelings about eating meat in
general but I do always try to make sure
it's you know humanely raised or all of
those things yeah that I think actually
make for a better piece of of meat
absolutely you know I agree with you on
that
but ultimately you're still killing the
animal I mean there's no question about
it
yeah mike is vegan yes yeah and he's
been slowly turning me man I mean I'm
still convinced you need to eat meat to
keep your muscle mass on but how not
what do you think it muscle man I know I
know as I get older and I hang out with
your yeah am I getting ready for battle
still I don't know I don't know but well
what do you like in what way are you
just eating less meat or are eating less
meat
sticking with fish now yeah much more
fish and chicken and why do you think it
is that people are like if you just look
at like one cow feeds
yeah whatever 400 people one fish feeds
one or two people why do you think
people who are vegans or you know or
vegetarians are on their way there will
a lot of them will still eat fish
specifically it's a good question I
guess if they have to really come down
to this what ledin are you a vegan yeah
yeah that's a big part of it and what
reason are you a vegan mostly from
health reasons one
not a vegan um I get overweight I can't
[ __ ] right I get constipated I'm
miserable my mood I'm depressed so yeah
I don't do well you feel better when
you're yes I feel 100% man oh praise be
to God yeah feel better
and you I have you know from years of
playing football and you know really
crazy relationships with food you know I
played in the NFL for six years
offensive line and I was 328 when I left
the league eating three massive meals a
day all the meat I could possibly eat
and you know I really felt slowed down
obviously when I came out of the league
I felt nauseated to eat you know I hated
eating at that point huh and I did a lot
of things I do a lot of fasting
intermittent fasting him down to about
250 now I did a lot of ketogenic which
is high fat but you know meat I have a
brother who's a vegan and he's been
preaching to me for years just about the
practices he's like do whatever you want
you know for me it's I don't I'm not
convinced of the health benefits of
being a vegan yet I don't think that
meat is as bad for you health-wise as
vegans would like to argue but to me the
one thing is that somewhere along the
line I just became a massive animal
lover and appreciator of nature and the
idea of if you're like me and you
believe that other animals are conscious
creatures and have an experience feeling
and emotion you know maybe they don't
have the same brain capacity as us to to
[ __ ] do all the [ __ ] that we do but
you know without a doubt animals are
conscious and so you can't deny that
when a cow see
that it's approaching this place where
his buddies have never come back from
there's a lot of fear hormones being
pumped a lot of adrenaline a lot of
cortisol you know these these hormones
that are fight or flight hormone so as
this animal is approaching death its
flesh is just being infused with all of
these fear hormones then it's killed and
then it's cut up and it's processed and
all the meat gets packaged up and sent
to us and then we cook it it's like
where did all that go do we really think
that that's just gone do we think that
those hormones never touch the piece of
flesh that we're eating I think we
always need to be aware of what we put
into our bodies and I look at food from
another perspective died and I look at
from a spiritual perspective yeah you
know I mean you give up a little you
gave up a little more you give up you
want to be you want to improve as a
person and then you think the more I get
up how would I how would I get closer to
God the most I give up the coastline get
to God is a sacrifice you feel
absolutely it's a purification
absolutely do you sacrifice in other
ways as well do you feel like like
fasting for some people you know it's a
way of getting closer to God I think of
giving everything even eating yeah well
you gotta eat at some point right and
they took what food I'm thinking what
grain and stuff yeah grains yeah so why
would you give up grains and beans no
this my spiritual journey
uh-huh and I wouldn't give it up I would
not give up my dreams and my beans but
you think about it no never
oh okay yeah no okay yeah save you're
not eating grains and beans what's left
center your vegetables vegetables yeah
being then grain and being the essence
of it yeah
seeds yeah we go we go [ __ ] crazy
here Jimmy yeah a lot of people smoke
and they get Cheetos and [ __ ] and yeah
yeah no Cheetos ma'am have you heard
about twink I just the first I'm hearing
about ah man unbelievable absolutely
absolutely yeah that's a CV pump water
let me ask you guys about CBD yes I'm
interested in this like you was it
really do anything yeah you think so
absolutely no everyone says yeah but
definitely like I get the stuff you rub
on your back or whatever and it's like
oh yeah it feels good for a second but
then I like AG it's the same thing from
like bengay or whatever you know I
wonder how much of it is psychosomatic
well the reason it works is because we
have this endocannabinoid system in our
body
thank you damn buddy so we have a whole
system in our body the endocannabinoid
system which produces endogenous
cannabinoids the same chemical compounds
found in cannabis CBD THC all that stuff
and why our body produces it or has an
endocannabinoid system is because it
creates homeostasis it regulates our
system or I don't know I'm pretending I
understand what it helps keep us in
balance it regulates your appetite your
mood your how you feel and deal with
pain how much of it should eat like do
you take CBD every day I do yeah I mean
I also smoke weed every day
mm-hmm you give it to is their CBD in
like a joint there is there's a certain
level of it yeah you know you make some
pot brownies and like you have no idea
how potent they are yes you cooked them
in a you know in your kitchen and it was
like good luck to everyone it's time to
eat these and then you're later and then
some people like would lose their minds
you know but I don't see that happening
anymore now that we're buying it is
happening yeah yeah I don't do any
edible activate and the thing with
edibles is boom you explode oh god with
happening at a party and event I figured
out how to handle edibles well yeah gets
too much and that's this and this is is
I think it's a great tip
for anyone who who goes too far you just
have to remind yourself you have to tell
yourself in 15 minutes it's gonna be
okay yeah just imagine you're on a
roller coaster or something you know
what's gonna be over and if you could
tell yourself that it'll be it'll be
okay that'll immediately calm you down
and take it I can't thank you be there
really Mike no I can't think of brownie
that's just [ __ ] that's the thing that
sends you [ __ ] out it has me scared I
can't get that guy miss what the [ __ ] is
going on interesting I didn't start
smoking until I was in my 30s really you
know I tried it a couple of times yeah
as younger but one of the first time
times I smoked like a high-grade joint
was with Mike really after the show and
I was completely out of my mind I was
completely out of my mind afterwards the
please I and I know I shouldn't have
done this but I got in my car and I had
to go host a charity event and I was
driving like 10 miles an hour I was on
the 405 driving like 10 miles an hour
and I got there and I was like somehow I
got through it
that's like Jesus all right that was not
that was not the pot of my youth sure
yeah
see there you go that's what I'm talking
what is it when it's all over than you
think it's and what do you want that
picture to look like mmm Jimmy Kimball
what it's all over yeah new me
personally mm-hmm um I guess you know I
think about like like my grandfather was
a very funny guy and be loved by all and
I think that's how I would like to be
remembered yeah like with like my
grandchildren be like all grandpa was so
funny you know that could that's I think
that would be the best way to be
remembered and then the other stuff is
you know the career stuff is all grow
it's fun and that it's rewarding but
that's the most I think that's like if
you want to have one legacy for me
that's it to be like that that's awesome
I think that's very awesome yeah how do
you like your drink it's good it's taste
like water right it's awesome
yes one is this one's got some flavor in
it there's a little bit of taste one of
the flavor ones yeah one may need to be
very there's pineapple orange or you got
watermelon
what should I try to everyone you want
I'll try the watermelon there you go
that appeals to me well you and Mike
have done a lot over the years yes right
yeah and they're very nice actually it's
nice it is good yeah that's nice and
that's you I wouldn't just I wouldn't
tamper with this one at all okay nice
excellent for me after all together we
play basketball we once got in the ring
together and I wanted a spar a little
and Mike said you know what I like you
too much to do that and he declined like
come on I just want just hit me once I
want to know what it feels like he said
that's not a good idea you were smart of
the way and you know we've done a lot of
we've sung together we've yeah we've we
always enjoy my time with you and I a
most guest you know it's talked about
the project and whatever but I always
love to hear your take on on things
because I think you have a lot of wisdom
and I think you've you've lived you've
had experiences in life that almost no
one else has and I kind of agree yeah
yeah and and there and to be able to
draw from those is so interests on to
talk to you it really is and I've always
been a fan I mean I you know as a
fighter you know I just I remember you
at like nineteen years old on the cover
of Sports Illustrated Kid Dynamite and
remember oh yeah I still probably have
that
and we would get so excited to see you
come out with no socks on and there's no
[ __ ] and just come out and just
knock the [ __ ] ass and you know growing
up in Vegas boxing was important to me
and and then to kind of to get to know
your personality and to see your
evolution from going from being a guy
who was you know whose job it was to
beat people up to this and all about
right yeah I mean it's it's it it seems
so different from you in a lot of ways
it's like it's hard to sometimes I have
to remind myself that you're the same
person that same kid who was yeah you
know exactly because you are a gentle
person
yeah ultimately and and that's I think
unusual in in this world for sure I
think in life I think um I'm gonna talk
about in life I'm talking about
everybody I'm talking about the Gnostics
and non-believer them whatever whoever
uses religion a goth whatever their
purpose their own agenda it comes with
time and a life and you start to
question their mortality and say whoa
why am I thinking like this what's
causing me to think like this why am i
who I am ya know who I think you've been
doing it for a long time and I think
it's um it's important to do that you
know I think that's that's I can kind of
almost remember I think when you started
thinking in that way and and it's great
you know I think it's it's it's a great
example for people I think we need to
get anything like my opinion of course
nobody else has to really listen that we
if we don't get to know who we are I
think it's a wasted life try to have an
idea of who we are I don't think we ever
really get the answer I mean one of the
things I remember about Mike that really
made a huge impression on me is
there was a time like the first few
years who were doing the show where we
had an idea to do a roast of Mike Tyson
roast on pay-per-view and like we
approached somebody about it and they're
like yeah this could make you know
whatever a huge amount of money a huge
amount of money and I went to Mike and I
said hey you know you know I was
thinking about you and I was thinking
like at that time I think things weren't
like going so well financially and I
said hey let's do this
and you can make you know III think it
was like 20 million dollars or something
like that and Mike said you know what
I've had a lot of money and I've not had
not so much money and I like myself
better when I don't have a lot of money
yeah and he said I that he didn't want
to do that because he didn't want the
money and I was like wow that's that's
pretty heavy
you know that's rare yeah and and I I
respected it and appreciate it and and
we didn't do it yeah absolutely I've
heard Mike say that it would have been
so easy I've you know it'll be similar
to ours a lot of money brings out my
demons yeah yeah my demons yeah well
it's good that you know that yeah yeah
absolutely
and now we're building this cannabis
Empire but you know I mean you could do
it the right way this time like these
plans you guys have are unbelievable I
mean it's unbelievable about us it's
crazy and it just gets you know the
vision grows all the time
the vision is bigger than Disneyland
yeah it's awesome we put together this
really badass doing camera so all right
and we want to give Jimmy Kimmel Live
exclusive premiering rights to a
commercial yeah what what a deal what a
deal that is for us
you mean we the things people would
normally pay for we could have for free
that's right all right
oh that let's check it out Rudy for this
after work you need to refresh relax
with some friends recovered from this
quagmire called life give you deserve a
drink any can have a twink stress less
twink more twink VCB d enhanced beverage
drink responsibly what do you think now
I like it I like the voiceover a guy
he's he's pretty good this is what we
don't go on to the next dimension is it
possible that I'm feeling a little high
from it no no I think you feel a nice
little yeah alright a lift just a little
lift I do right ok cuz they always say
it doesn't really I'm telling you
brother
yeah no I'm definitely feeling a little
a very pleasurable something right now
Eric you all want yeah Eric have one
yeah which one would you like man Vic
what are you doing up workout in do you
get training obviously I don't get
enough workout in I I do work out three
times a week but I mostly try to keep
conversations with my trainer going so
that I don't really have to work out
that much
yeah it's a really it's a trick on your
only on yourself really so good I just
paid $100 - uh yeah - a [ __ ] with
somebody about a YouTube video
hey men you got to get your breaths and
you know right how about your back and
forth with trunk well it's more force
than back it's not like he really
responds to these hearing it dude maybe
he's feeling yeah he does love hearing
him I know he knows that not just me I
know he knows that he's not thought well
thought of in in the late-night
community yeah but he is it's hard
because he does so many weird and
obnoxious things every single day yeah
some days it's like oh my god am i is he
gonna be the main subject again and you
know my if I have any kind of like a a
just kind of plan for the show or
whatever just like an overall thought on
the show it's that we talk about the
current of the events of the day
yeah and that's you know so what
everyone's talking about all the time
it's hard to get around it how do you
feel about the state of things right now
very bad yeah very bad I think that like
maybe at the top of the list is one of
the most boring subjects is climate
change and I mean we can feel it you
know you could just you just know like
Oh Jeff ran through the heat wave yeah
it's just I've never even Europe was 108
degrees in Paris yeah
this is not a this is not a coincidence
and you know I know you you reading
somebody will say oh it's ten years and
it's gonna be a hellscape and then
people say no no if we don't get
together in 18 months it's gonna be and
who knows what that what time you know
the timeframe is but I don't wanna even
if there's a 2% chance that we're
[ __ ] this planet up for our children
or our grandchildren we should take that
very seriously
yeah and the only comfort I get is
knowing that these fossil fuel
businesses these people will also have
to live on this planet and they will
suffer the same consequences that we do
but unfortunately the the poorest people
will will suffer the most and well you
know that dude Scott Pruitt yeah the
belief behind it is that God will
replenish he's right
God will replenish God will eliminate
the human race and he will replenish the
planet yeah exactly it's just like [ __ ]
man why do you why do we want to be here
and just [ __ ] burn it all to the
ground you know especially when it's not
like somebody saying okay but you have
to stop driving right you don't have to
stop driving right there are other ways
to drive we have an electric car I'm a
big fan of it
yeah I do too it's great it's [ __ ]
awesome it's great it's got good pickup
it's like uh it's super quick yeah it's
great I believe in that yeah yeah I mean
you want us to buy a Tesla yeah because
the doors go up on the side that's a
girl like I want a Tesla or [ __ ] sick
the coolest thing about the Tesla is
that it like a computer they add they
can add features yeah to the software
where do i plug it up at not just get a
plug in your in your house yeah plugs
right in then and you actually the state
of California I don't know if they're
still doing it but they do a big rebate
for getting an electric car I think
that's the chargers I think that's been
I think it's diminished over the years I
might be nothing
ours was really good yeah and we oat
meal out there among grapes hey guys
that's a great question and his grapes
don't forget the great Wow Mike look at
all the people looking for your old man
well is it worse Mike's oatmeal awesome
well I gotta bring this up on the show
there's two things I want to talk about
thank yes please thank you brother here
we get a spoon
is there a spoon a me thank you
that's not honey is it how do you feel
about this situation at the border it's
monstrous [ __ ] discussing it you know
what it's it's cruelty for no absolutely
no reason it's crazy
which brings to mind I mean thank you
and thank you Emmy I'm just saying that
God knows where this thing is headed if
it's allowed to continue and who just
speaking of God most of these people who
support this call themselves Christians
right and just I don't know what church
they went to or what Bible they're
reading but the one I know would frown
on putting children in a cage and
separating them from their parents and I
understand you can't have open borders
you have to have to there's a process
and the truth is is that anybody that
sneaks in gets ahead of anybody who did
it the right way but you have to be you
have to have some just measure of
humanity I mean you know the idea that
we're going to deter people from coming
over the border by treating them
horribly is as unamerican a sentiment
and unchristian a sentiment as I can I
mean it's it's it is the most
combination of the most on America this
country that was built by immigrants and
and our Statue of Liberty you know
welcomes our poor are tired and are
hungry and you know I mean he might as
well take that Statue of Liberty down
because it obviously doesn't mean
anything yeah
it's just amazing the light this this
entire the more immigrants we get the
more prisoners with a build that's how
it is that's how it always been his
prisons make people money yeah we have
private prisons no private people home
so they could feed you and clothe you do
anyone - yeah and treat you - anyone -
and in any society needs a supply of
hard-working immigrants to continue I
mean you need it it's it's necessary
this whole country was [ __ ] started
by immigrants yeah it's so easy to say
like alright shut the door behind me now
I'm here and this is mine but this
country belongs to to all of us it's
pretty [ __ ] maddening where are we
headed like what's next
well I hope that we look back on this
time as as temporary insanity hmm I
doubt that's gonna be the case short of
some kind of justifiable war that unites
us all I don't see how our next leader
whoever that may be is going to unite us
I mean I think it's it's gonna be we're
just split in half and and there seems
to be no common ground whatsoever
there's none and and I mean even now
like we could have a wildfire and it
becomes partisan we can have a hurricane
in in Puerto Rico and it becomes a
partisan these things that used to be
just like yeah okay okay there's a
disaster we're all on board to help now
suddenly become political it's just like
it's just it's not productive in any way
listen here's the thing I understand you
know I have relatives I have my wife as
relatives who who think Donald Trump is
is it's good for this country but here's
what no one can deny this man whether
you like him or not
is a liar he is a compulsive liar he
lies every single day he lies about
things he doesn't have to lie about and
do we want political thinking of that I
think it's he's something he's found
success with I think he started just
exaggerating his own achievements and
his own appeal I mean we know the guy
who called the newspaper and say as as
as his own publicist and say Donald
Trump is dating Salma Hayek you know and
and just what [ __ ] story and at that
time okay whatever it's harmless to
everyone other than Salma Hayek but I I
think he can't help himself that lying
is his is his first inclination and we
cannot have a president whose first
inclination is to is to lie and attack
the thing that's gonna happen
I think he's gonna lose the next
election and I think the people who
support him are gonna do everything they
can to thwart our next leader and I
think we're gonna keep repeating this
cycle over and over again what I hope
doesn't happen is I hope we don't look
back at this time almost wistfully or we
go like wow things we thought things
were bad was president is good time yeah
we thought things were bad that I mean I
think in a certain way a lot of people
who are uh you know I was no fan of the
Bush presidency but now I look back on
it and go like what did George please
come back yeah well hopefully he doesn't
win again what do you think about the
opiate situation they would deal it now
it's terrible I mean it's a pen and I'm
talk to me I think that well I mean I
think that it's just so easy to slip
into that and I think that doctors a lot
of doctors are irresponsibly providing
people with those opiates and that's a
big reason for our homelessness problem
here in Los Angeles because that's where
next thing this is where you come I mean
there's no better place to be homeless
if you
gonna be homeless in here it's we have a
warm climate and I think that are a big
reason why the numbers are going up is
because people are coming here young
people who are hooked on drugs are
coming here and living in the streets I
know to do with the homeless people what
do you what do you do all these rich
billionaire guys are gonna all donate
money we're gonna build like wow
a homeless hotel it's just so
complicated but it is there you know
there are homeless shelters but a lot of
almost people don't want to be in them
because they're dangerous because the
people that are dangerous and and there
are homeless people who don't want it
who don't want to be yeah to live in a
place like that so it's you know and
then if you have a family you know is
that where you want your family to be do
or do you feel safer on the street or
living in your car you know it's very
complicated I don't know that placated
just bill I think it has to be
decentralized it has to be a lot of
small communities and and you know and
is it fair to only ask these business
leaders I mean I think we should all
pitch it you know and and and pay for
this but the problem is is it's not just
writing a check it's not like a lot of
things like you know your lunch program
you could fix that with money yeah this
one is so very complicated it is of
course we can't fix it overnight but
that's that's for the best minds about
know essentially yeah this has been
happening since the beginning of time of
course well how did I'm how do you think
you handles the homelessness yeah it's
so complicated it is
so maybe the momentum layers issue yeah
because it's not as simple you know you
hear people go man get a [ __ ] job
it's not that simple
for some it is but for right now for
some it is that simple it's a issue of I
don't know inspiration or engagement but
it's not that simple for everyone you
know Jimmy man I really appreciate you
coming it was my pleasure my pleasure
our time here for sure thank you so much
I think I'm all CBD DUP right now yeah
you're perfect in the family thank you
Eric thanks for coming in st. Louis
Jimmy well thanks guys that was great
that was fun is there anything else you
want to shout out anywhere people can
find you I don't know people can find me
on the street is hanging out eating
chicken but no you know I have a
television show and Mike I always enjoy
our time together and I'm really
inkstand agree and I'm excited about
your pot Disneyland in the desert
I really have to come out really awesome
they have a miracle I'm with that first
round a ferris wheel
yeah ferris wheel lazy river you got to
come to the next kind music festival oh
yeah Mike has a music festival out at
the property in Desert Hot Springs oh
wow well thanks guys thank you thank you
Mike
great episode and when this is our
favorite yeah I think this is our this
is our favorite episode what are you
doing to leave here we leave you know I
got the kids I have two little kids they
slept over my mother-in-law's house last
night so we'll go retrieve them and hang
out on the beach a little bit and then
I'm going to a birthday party later oh
yeah awesome nice little Saturday yeah
hotboxing little time with the family
right birthday party there you go
beautiful
Mike yes love you brother
ditto thank you very much hey everybody
thanks for watching this very special
episode of hot box and be sure to
subscribe to our YouTube channel hot
boxing with Mike Tyson
check us out our website hot box in
podcast.com got all the episodes there
as well as some badass merch for you to
check out until next time i'm evan
britain i'm mike i think this is so with
all these people
I know it's beautiful now they bring you
bring them in Mike my thank you very MUC
ich them out peace everybody out of here
Thank You Jimmy thank you
[Music]